[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
open phones this hour the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five you can get in if you dial at
this moment that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the dr john deloney
show is my co-host today open phones
again at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're gonna be talking
about your relationships talk about
mental health about jobs about career
about money we're going to talk about
you right in front of you
so john you and i were actually talking
earlier this morning in a meeting and um
discussing things around your book new
book coming out
that with
all the wackiness happening in the world
that
i mean your book and some of the
materials that you're putting out are
all about
dealing with your past
um you know own your past change your
futures the title the new book but this
idea that that you know things that have
happened to me as an individual or to
you guys out there as an individual the
trauma that you experienced
during covid or the trauma experience
from family or the trauma you
experienced from a job or whatever
trauma wherever it was
that's kind of like one set of
anxiety-inducing things you call them
bricks in the backpack right
and then there's a whole nother set of
anxiety-inducing things and both of
these affect money they affect job they
affect marriage because it affects
mental health basically uh but the
anxiety-inducing trauma type things are
um i mean stuff like russia and ukraine
yeah uh stuff like out of control
inflation used cars are going up
all right which makes me think i'm in a
cartoon or something i mean i'm instead
of real life and this must be a pixar
movie i mean how to use cars to go up is
impossible and uh you know uh supply
chain stuff is just bizarre
uh just trying to get something
purchased and get it shipped to you
uh is crazy so environmental type things
that are impacting us the new negative
news we'll just call it and then you've
got things that are individual to you in
your life that makes sense absolutely
two different buckets how do you deal
with those different buckets you know i
was
on an interview yesterday and talking
about this exact thing and
what i told the the guy was man
i woke i tell people for a living to get
off your devices that's that's one of my
cornerstone messages get off your
devices and be with the real people i am
to go exercise and do my morning routine
like i always do and the first thing i
did was pull out my phone to see if
putin had invaded
and instead of looking at it and seeing
there's tension and closing it and going
about my day i sat there and sat there
went to this new site and this new site
this new site alice went down the rabbit
hole huh yes and i missed my workout i
missed everything i grabbed coffee and i
was able to high-five my kids and i head
out the door
instead of and here's the thing nothing
there's not a thing i can do about that
but no one else can either by the way
what i what i could do was i could have
got my exercise in i could have made my
wife's coffee and brought it to her
because i know that little tiny acts of
service when i'm stressed out helps calm
me down i could have written a note to
my kids and said hey i got an early
morning of media hits i love you guys i
miss you i could have done some things
that i know
bring me peace and bring my anxiety
level down instead of fed it and so what
i what i can control and lean in on
those and literally use the off button
on some of these things you can check on
russia once or twice a day and that's it
nothing else is going to change
and if it does there's nothing you could
do about it right yeah or the inflation
or the get your house unless you're on
the joint chiefs for staff you don't
need to be riding it all day long you
can't ride it all day long and here's
the thing because it'll ride you it will
bury you it will bury you my heart rate
is up as though america's getting
shelled right now and we're not right
we're not and so then stick your head in
the sand and avoid it no this is a
worldwide issue we all need to be on uh
in the know on this
but get in the know and then get back
out don't go swimming and bathing in the
cesspool
right get what you need and then get out
of there man and then deal with your
people in your life yeah the the problem
is
inputs matter
i mean and if you're incredible if all
you do is fee and that includes who you
hang around with it includes what you
read it includes your screen which you
want yeah it includes if you're includes
podcasts you get off work and you listen
to you listen to a murder podcast on the
way home just you can get to law and
order svu right yeah for dinner like
you're just feeding yourself this stuff
yeah inputs matter because if you put if
all your inputs are crap your brain's
crap your brain is terrified all day
it's fight or flight all day all day and
then a real thing shows up like
inflation like you go to the grocery
store and you look at your budget and
say
oh i got to make some choices on meat or
vegetables this month that's a real
thing that you need to be able to handle
those issues that is taken up by other
fake
drama right it's just going to go and go
and go and it going
so you do really need to identify
causes of stress and put them in one or
two buckets things i can do something
about things i can't that's right things
i can't you need to limit the inputs
absolutely all day every day just just
just stop i had a friend's watching cnn
watching fox all day long i think we're
i think he's in a rubber room now yeah i
mean it's michael all day long
100 of it is hyped yep exaggerated and
bad yes that's exactly i mean it's just
like you know eat i i'm gonna eat
chocolate bars all day long 24 7
and then think that's going to work out
from a nutrition standpoint i mean you
know or whatever negative thing you can
come up with to eat but i mean that
would gag you if you got past four of
them you know but
it just
your mind is gagging that's right and
it's a little bit heightened right now
we should all be anxious right now this
is a big deal right and i'm i'm i'm
anxious to see what my government's
going to do to participate or not
participate and what my leadership's
going to look like all that's true and
real and good prices are real the gas i
can't even like i have to double take
when you drive by a gas station right
all this stuff's real
and then what can i do about that i
can't fix the gas prices today and so
i'm going to see it and i'm going to go
man that's that's that stinks i'm going
to have to make some adjustments in my
budget with my wife and then i'm going
to go it's going to make me a ball of
rage that's going to affect my kids my
wife my family my neighborhood and my
work you got to control the
controllables and set the rest of them
and control the things that aren't
controllable right that's right that's
why they're not called controllable so i
mean this is not hard yeah and yet we
have gotten into this between social
media 24-hour news cycle
um
i mean it used to be
you know walter cronkite for 30 minutes
in the evening your local news for 30
minutes in the evening and you had a
newspaper some of you don't know what
that is you could look it up on the
internet but
um and that was you know you were stuck
with that yeah and a lot of that was
hours and hours and hours behind but
then you had to go sit down with real
humans and you got the dinner you got
the pontification circles well i think
this well i think this you're engaging
with real people and a real human would
say i think that's dumb i think this and
i think that and you had real
interactions and your body actually goes
okay we're safe i got a real person
right here i got a real person right
here we're exchanging ideas and now it's
just grenade grenade grenade grenade
digital grenades that's right yeah
that's right which are about as bad as
digital courage yeah wow
scary times man scary times but you have
to control the situation you have to
control your environment it's uh you're
not gonna get out of this otherwise
that's right dr john deloney ramsey
personality dave ramsey the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five
two two five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
over the last 30 years we've helped
people with a lot of stresses around the
money subject we've also witnessed a lot
of other kinds of stress anxiety and
loneliness we're just talking about in
the last segment dr john's new book is
out of the pre-sale on it is out own
your past change your future you can
change the story on your future your
past has some legitimate things that
have happened to you most of us have
experienced that right
and you can learn how to deal with all
kinds of different kinds of kinds of
trauma get connected to a community make
friends as an adult your mental health
matters
you'll get a free bonus including a one
including a month of free one-on-one
therapy so pre-order your own copy of
own your past change your future it's
only twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com
it'll be out in april and we'll get it
shipped to you so it's 20 bucks and you
get all the pre-sale items if you get it
on pre-sale for 20 bucks dave ramsey
solutions dot com dale is in boise hi
dale welcome to the ramsey show
yeah thank you for having me on sure
what's up
um so i got a question for you i mean we
pretty much have solved you know all the
baby steps
owned several pieces of property free
and clear pretty much dumped all our
money into
paying everything off um but here later
in life
we decided to build a rv park because it
seems to be kind of the trend
and um
we have an sba loan but
we can't pay the loan off as fast as we
would like to because there's a really
hefty
repayment penalty so it's like well what
do we do
you know with the extra money that that
we can't
you know run like we usually do
you know keep keeping it you know
everything paid off low profile i mean
we've had the same cars that we've had
for 25 years we don't just go what's the
balance on the sba loan
uh 1.8 million
ouch
and it has a prepayment penalty on a two
million dollar loan
that's really unusual
10 years it's uh two point three eight
percent interest
fixed for 20-year amortization but we
can't pay it off for ten
ten years
and uh
how many years on the ten how long ago
would you do this mess
we just we just flipped from the
construction
takeout to the permanent finance team
good lord
have you done the math on the difference
between the prepayment penalty and the
interest you would save by paying it off
early
it's um 25
of the loan
so it's substantial
you know you're looking at you know 425
thousand dollar prepayment only good god
almighty
at what point in the process did you not
stop and go this is a dumb butt idea
well the the cash flow makes it
worthwhile
of doing but hypothetically
unless nobody comes to an rv park
because there's a pandemic and then you
go bankrupt
and you took out a prepayment penalty of
25
and willingly knowingly signed up for
that
wow dude government
at its finest i mean that's what i said
no no no
the government didn't have a gun to your
head you signed the paper the the lender
can make up whatever wacko terms they
want to you have you have feet to walk
away and you're supposed to use them man
oh my god all right so do you have any
money
uh very little cash on hand right now
most of all of our uh s fast money has
went into the
construction because the prices of
everything have went up 200 to 300
percent hold on hold on it's not hold on
it's not because of the prices it's
because you chose to spend it
yeah your whole orientation is everybody
did this to you
yeah
or like it was out of your control you
know like you didn't have a choice to do
all this so all right you've done it now
i'm gonna quit beating on you so here's
the deal
uh what you've got to do is you need to
save up 1.8 million dollars as fast as
you can and set it in an investment to
the side
so that when the 10-year clock goes
ding-ding you write a check
and um you need you need a tremendous
amount of liquidity no you don't need to
pour anything else into this
freaking rv park
no
uh you're already deep in it so what you
need to do is take any money you can
find from anywhere and begin an
investment pool on the side to pay this
loan off the day it hits
the um
[Music]
the the day it gets down small enough
that you can that you want to bite the
bullet on the prepayment penalty or the
day it hits the 10-year mark and you
write that check so you need a mutual
fund that the target on it is i want to
put 1.8 million dollars in
and you better hope that gas doesn't get
up to four dollars and 50 cents a bear i
mean a gallon again people quit
taking their rvs out as much as they
have the last few years yeah yeah again
dang man that's heartbreaking you're
going to be stuck in your old cars for a
season man you put yourself in big rates
interest rates go up you know what
happens to rv sales
i stop and when gas prices go up people
quit toting around the country and
saying man
yeah
i'm just a barrel we're just barely good
news today but um i tell you anyway but
yeah that's something good happened to
you call today too
so yeah the answer to your question is
no you don't put money back into the
business yes you pound money on the side
as fast as you can politics the highest
you can pilot so you've got liquidity
because you have a bigger mess on your
hands than you perceive
and that's why we're both kind of we
have both have both of us john and i
have a little panic in our voice that
you are not experiencing in your body
and when that does hit your body someday
i want you to have a big pile of money
because it's coming yeah it's um take
ownership of your choices brother take
ownership
so guys um
i can feel it on you man
all right just all right joy is in
cincinnati hey joy what's up
hi i am so honored thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up dave and
dr dahlani
i am a retired law enforcement officer i
get a pension
but i listened to dave ramsey and i went
back to work part time so actually i'm
sitting in the parking lot right now
getting ready to go in
um and every time i want to
quit i keep ain't nope dave will say no
anyway my husband is a was an active
duty um well career marine
he also retired uh he gets a pension
but he does have a lot of service
service-related problems he did get a
full-time job with the post office but
it just got so bad on him he had to quit
his full-time job
with them we still get a pension
but we're struggling just you know i
want to get us out of debt and i'm i'm
struggling i should say what's your
question for our run out of time
i'm sorry
we have a 19 year old son at home he's
our only child we started late
my husband treats him
like he's still six my husband's the
heart marshmallow i'm the mean one
i want him to get out of the house get a
job and help you know if he's going to
stay there i want him to pay
like almost rent
um and he won't he won't get out of his
room he sits on his computer and plays
games i don't want him to hate me
because i have to be the mean one to get
him to do something
your husband's the main one yeah your
husband's handicapping that poor boy
hurting him
he doesn't see it that way and my
husband also has traumatic brain injury
so
i'm walking on eggshells with that ptsd
traumatic brain injury so if you take
your 19 year old and you tell him that
he's got
30 days or 60 days or 90 days to go find
a job and get out he's going to be mad
at you and he's going to say mean things
if you let him live there till he's 30
then he's gonna hate you when he was
four and you made him brush his teeth he
got mad too
and it was the right thing to do but we
still made him brush his freaking teeth
that's right because we love him and he
needs teeth when he's older
it feels like he might be a blanket a
security blanket for your husband right
now and i'm not saying that facetiously
i get that he he's a
he's a probably a therapy pet for your
husband right now right he's somebody
that that your husband can count on
he's gone
he stays in his room because you all
allow it and stays in his room because
y'all allow it right it's got to stick
it's got to stop
he needs to move out mom yeah
you got to love him enough
to move him out
he needs to get it's time it's time he's
functioning on a 14 year old level
because you're letting him
and it's not going to work out well
because he's not ever he's never going
to meet the special someone because
they're not going to come to his room
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
your latest looks and see how much you
can save at blinds.com today the easy
and affordable way to make your home
more beautiful is blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back we're glad you're here
america dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money joe is in st louis hey
joe welcome to the ramsay show
hey dr john and dave thanks for taking
my question i'll try to make it brief we
are in baby step five thanks to you
guys's plan good for you um
and we did it we kind of did like a 3b
to save for my car i've got an old
corolla and it's still running great
would it be okay to take some of that
money and then max out um our rough iras
for the year
and then kind of rebuild that 3d backup
just because the market's down i figure
it's probably a good time to invest oh i
see so you would be putting in over 15
percent
15
at baby step 4 already into your
retirement are you not
yes we are but right now we're kind of
doing it we just drafted out monthly oh
you can't put a lump sum in it right now
yeah as long as the total for the year
is not more than 15 percent of your
income that would be fine yes
yes that's correct okay
but if you're if you're saying should i
invest more into retirement than fifteen
percent of my income while i still have
a mortgage no i would not tell you to do
that no yeah we just have the money for
the car
but the corolla just keeps going so we
were just uh
wondering if we could do we've been
there man
and it's a crummy time to buy a car yeah
because they're outrageously priced
right now
so
um
you know i mean you can get a car but if
you and sometimes people need a car
right now but if you just
you got a car that's working and you
don't have to move it so uh what happens
if the corolla lays down what are we
gonna do
uh well like we still have uh
enough to
buy something that would work and if we
needed to i guess take an extra two or
three grand out of the emergency fund we
could do that yeah then as long as
you're not over 15 you got
you kind of thought through the uh what
ifs then yeah i'd dive in on it for sure
have at it bro ah solomon is with us
solomon is in new york city hi solomon
welcome to the ramsey show
hi there dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so i'll try to keep it short but
basically
i called the show a couple months back
and you told me that because i'm so
young i should just stash away cash
uh for now
in savings
and so now i've been doing that but i'm
keeping keeping obviously a couple
couple hundred
just like
in my checking account
and i've been recently i got approached
by a few people who are collecting for
charity besides the ties
and i can't help but be a little bit
like
have a bad feeling when i'm giving them
money
or not giving them as much as a
as i could
you know i i so my question is how do i
stop that from happening
that feeling
yeah
um
i have never been able to stop it from
happening
and it doesn't matter how much money i
give and how much money i have allocated
to give there's always
wonderful things that need help
wonderful ideas of helping people
uh there's a whole lot more places to
give that are valid than i'll ever have
money
yeah
that's kind of what it feels like yeah
and so when i kind of get that my wife
makes fun of me and she says that's
jesus's job that job's taken you're not
him
you can't solve everything by yourself
all you can do is solve what's put in
front of you with a reasonable ratio of
what you have
and then release it because you're not
going to be the answer to all the
world's problems in other words neither
am i and i have to relearn that because
i feel that's the exact same tension i
felt it this morning
because we have a budget
an amount laid out that we do giving on
our family foundation and a thing popped
up into my email this morning from my
daughter that's the director and and i
wanted to do more than we should
because i like the idea of what it was
and my wife said nope this is what we're
doing and i'm like yep that's what we're
doing because we're not jesus it's his
job i feel that i feel that same thing i
think everybody does so yeah here's the
thing you will not become stingy because
people that ask this question never
become stingy
you don't have to worry about being
selfish but what you do have to learn to
manage is the tension of you can't solve
everything be everywhere have enough
money to fix everyone's hurts and if you
give yourself into a hole
go back to college i used to pick up
tabs for people or pick fill their gas
up if they look like they needed it but
i did it on a credit card right i dug
myself a hole thinking i was being a
hero
and it didn't work right that you run
out of air at some point so make sure
you've taken care of yourself you're not
good to anybody if you're not taking
care of yourself if you're not whole so
you know i th there's two things one is
you're not a selfish person because
selfish people don't mess this question
right and when you get more money you
become more of what you already are so
you're gonna be okay yeah number one
number two you're always going to have
attention and you have to release it and
say i'm not god that's his job
i'm he's going to put in front of me
what i can do and i'm going to do what i
can do and not bring harm to my family
while i'm helping other families and
other people and um and that's the
balance of it
uh
so that that's how i that's how i've
done it but i i will tell you that i
feel this exact same tension
yeah so uh josiah is with us in omaha hi
josiah how are
you doing well thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so i have a vanguard retirement fund
that tracks it's just a mutual fight now
you always can get confused etf to
mutual funds but attracts with the you
know stock markets and what i was
reading is that we're going to enter
into a bear market and
that one article suggested i invest i do
dollar cost averaging
invest in commodities i was looking at a
mutual fund that just temporarily did
you read the article that said you're
supposed to send it all to dave ramsey
or john deloney yeah um because that
article is out there
no it's not it's not out there but
just because you read on the internet
doesn't mean it's right
yeah matter of fact that probably
invalidates it
that's true
so otherwise i wouldn't be here but it
would still be i know i know that in
times of
volatile times you know you're not
supposed to have major emotional
reactions
but
he who right he who jumps off a roller
coaster in the middle of the ride is he
who gets hurt
finish the ride my brother exactly
finish the ride my brother
so continue to invest but i do you know
what the right question i guess is like
the 10 000 millionaires that we studied
that became millionaires
the number of them that jumped out of
their investments into commodities
because they read an article and that
made them wealthy when things were scary
in the news was precisely zero
none of them did that
none of them did that they kept
investing and they kept investing and
they kept investing when it was scary
when it was wild when it was fun when it
was good when people are smiling when
they're frowning when they're cussing
and when they're singing joyful noises
all the time they just keep on investing
just keep on investing just keep on
investing you can call it dollar cost
averaging if you want to call it that
but that's not the advantage to it the
advantage of it is you don't stop
investing and you don't change horses in
the middle of a flood
while you're in the middle of the stream
you're gonna drown no no no no no and
quit reading stupid butt articles on the
internet because it'll cause you to do
this stuff
oh man i've got a friend that got cancer
or he's got a cancer scare may have
cancer may not
and um
i said listen do not listen the cancer
might get you but i will 100 guarantee
you i'm going to kill you if you google
and start reading about cancer on the
freaking internet because you are going
to get bad information a bunch of goobs
on there with opinions about
the tomato seeds or whatever else they
dream up and i'm going to pound you if
you open your computer and type in the
word cancer there is one
whenever i see articles like this i
always go to what's the incentive and
there's somebody who's got a commodities
trading office that makes money on the
exchange that looks for precisely folks
like you josiah who are trying to pay
attention who love their families who
are a little bit scared and they say hey
come over here come over here and you're
going to jump off and you're going to
give them your money well let's do it
the other thing is this very very seldom
do you actually get conned by a real con
man right but you can get conned by an
enthusiastic ignoramus
and there's a whole lot more of those
than there are con maybe you just
described social media
i did you did one phrase what phrase
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we talk about mental health as we
talk about relationships jobs career
money it's all right here on the ramsey
show by the way we're going to be doing
a relationships and mental health theme
hour soon
which will of course include dr john
delony and uh that's so we're gonna take
questions on in that hour about marriage
parenting family friendships boundaries
your own mental health anxiety
depression
all the things that fall under those
categories relationships of all kinds so
if you want to be part of that you can
go to ramseysolutions.com
ask put mental health in the subject
line kelly i'll get back to you to
schedule you for a call and to be part
of that female if you have questions
about those things you can talk about
them today too here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five ramsey
solutions dot com slash ask put mental
health in the subject line and we'll do
a relationships and mental health theme
hour together you and me and dr john all
right matthew's in buffalo new york hey
matthew how are you
oh i've seen better days but i can't
complain if i'm being honest how are you
doing today better than i deserve sir
how can i help
better than i deserve to i love hearing
that um a little nervous um bear with me
um i just want to say thank you mr
ramsey and dr john you guys have helped
me um
so much uh that you guys won't see the
back end of but emotionally spiritually
financially i want to thank you guys for
all that you do i listen to the youtube
channel all the time almost every single
day thank you how can we help today sir
my question so my question here today is
i have made a giant mistake and i've
neglected um a couple bills and they've
gone to collections and so
well background i'm 19 years old i'm
young i'm stupid and i'm glad i'm making
a mistake today so i'll have to make it
with a bigger mistake later and like i
said these have bills have gone to
collections and they're about up to 800
and i was wondering if i should
call these collections companies and
get these
sorted out through a credit card or
through my debit card because if they go
through and
um overcharge me and it goes through a
credit card it'll be easier to dispute
it with the credit card company versus
the debit card company i've had issues
with both and it's been
fixed with the credit card much easier
than the debit card and getting my money
back so i just want to
get your advice and thoughts on what i
should do where i should start
and that's it so thanks uh for that okay
thank you what are the bills for what
did you not pay
um so i did not pay um some toll bills
um for like driving over bridges and
that kind of things and like i said
they're up to eight hundred dollars oh
it's all and then you solve that one
thing
yeah it's all one thing over the course
of uh about a year now and i was young
stupid and neglected them okay all right
thank you for taking responsibility yeah
we've all been there man that's a good
that's a good first start for all of us
to take responsibility for what we do
and cause
um
so no i would not use a credit card
because i as you know from i know you're
against credit card i would not have a
credit card so first thing i would do is
take some scissors and place across that
thing and squeeze hard have plastic
surgery and um
yeah then close that account so okay
that answered that part now the debit
card yeah you're right i would not give
them electronic access to your checking
account which your debit card does do
and so i would not use that to settle a
collection so you were onto something
there what i would do is just find out
the amount
exactly by having a phone call or an
email exchange with the collector
and say all right if i get back on the
phone with you in a few hours
uh what will be the amount
okay
and then go buy a prepaid debit card for
exactly that amount to the penny
and then give and then give them that
and then cut that up because it's a
one-time use item
gotcha so what about a money order with
that you could do that too that's fine
you just or you could do a wire you can
do a wire if you want to as long as
they're not having your debit card or or
they don't have your checking account
number
and matthew i even i have a it's a
digital version of this i have a service
that i use that's free it's online that
i put my debit card number in and it
gives me an unlimited number of
numbers of debit card numbers that i can
use for vendors online and i get to say
what the max payout is so if it gets
taken you can't go any further does that
work what's that called privacy.com okay
this is what i use you can try that is
it free it's free yeah it's fantastic
but i put my number in that way tom
do up
privacy.com yeah and i put my debit card
in there and then any of my online
purchases i don't want online companies
having my access to my checking account
and so i can say you can own the any
purchase can only be this much amount
but again there's probably a dozen of
those kind of companies out there and
obviously do your due diligence but um
like dave said yeah
don't ever give them access to your
account yeah that's the big thing and
you know get in writing it'd be great if
they just send you an email back and say
if you pay by
the 15th of
of march then it'll be this amount and
then you've got that in writing and you
keep keep that in a file in hard copy
and you keep a hard copy of
whatever methodology you used to pay in
the file so this if this ever comes up
again you've got proof that it was all
settled out
and uh the great news is you're now on
top of your money and you're gonna
handle things pay your tolls matthew
well done there you go
all right christy's in charlotte north
carolina hi christy how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i have a
well two kids one's already in college
and my son is a high school junior he's
16 and started working and he saved
about five thousand dollars so far
his goal is to be debt free
his college he doesn't want to he wants
to have a debt-free degree
um
right now he has three thousand dollars
in savings 800 in checking and he had
bought some stocks he invested
700 and um
then it went up to about 1500 it's down
about 1200 now and i called one of your
coaches earlier and asked he wanted to
know if he should invest part of that
savings for three thousand dollar
savings into a mutual fund and they said
no because he'll need the money and
follow he wants to go to community
college first and then to a state school
so he'll need the money in fall of 2025.
and um they said no don't invest into a
mutual fund i forgot to ask him about
the stocks whether he should keep well
they're more volatile than mutual funds
you know right
but he already had those he said not to
invest more of the savings into mutual
funds but we didn't
know what should he sell those i would
catch him
i'd cash it out and put it in the
savings
okay
trap your wins
and uh avoid the losses uh here and
there's two reasons for that
okay one is is that um
you know we're protecting the money that
he has made and it's not gonna go down
further with geopolitical events in the
air we don't know exactly what the stock
market will do in the next six months
it's not a time to be screwing around
with single stocks the second thing
that's more important than that
this because it's 700 or 1200 or
whatever it ends up being is not going
to cause him to be able to go to school
or keep him from going to school
it doesn't answer right it doesn't solve
the problem so if we lit it on fire it
doesn't end the him going to school
theory right
so
so what we really do with it doesn't
matter that much
but what does matter is what he believes
causes him to win
and if he starts to see himself as a
wonderful stock market day trader he's
setting himself up for losses for the
next three decades
before he figures out that's a dumb butt
idea
um and so i don't want to
strengthen a muscle that i don't want
people using
yeah that was kind of his fun money that
was that was not his work money yeah i
know but i mean it's kind of like it's
kind of like let's say he dropped by the
casino and dropped a quarter in and it
came out 300 bucks
and but and then he did that again and
it worked again uh then he starts to
think that's where wealth comes from
yeah see we we let him buy those stocks
with the thought that it would probably
go down and he would learn his lesson
brutal hey listen if when i was his age
i would have taken that money and bought
laffy taffy so y'all are way ahead of
the game matter of fact you might do
that now i probably wouldn't that's why
i take most of my ramsey paycheck
um to the cafe and the dentist but but
yeah shift that man he's on the right
track just shift where he's aiming those
that financial that financial weaponry
and um something that's more sustainable
yeah
when you're teaching kids about money
and letting them participate in
different types of financial instruments
understand that you are
that the actual dollars that are moving
around don't matter much but what the
the lesson that you're teaching them is
this is the way to do it
and that's you know it's like well he'll
learn to be responsible if he has a
credit card no he won't he'll learn to
use credit cards that's right you know
that's don't give a teenager a credit
card dumber rock because you're gonna
have an adult with a credit card later
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your questions
about your relationships your mental
health your job your career your money
your life
we talk about it all right here on the
ramsay show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
john it is really popular right now to
hate rich people because they're evil
and they're greedy and we should hate
all of them agreed anyone who is
successful should be
completely torn down they should not be
allowed to be successful because we want
everyone to be at the same level because
we are now a bunch of communists and so
greedy rich people horrible evil rich
people are everywhere and we have
decided that because the horrible evil
greedy rich people are everywhere that
james our producer decided we're going
to start exposing
how horrible and greedy and evil they
are
pretty regular basis
so carissa collins is the owner of the
popular instagram account the collins
kids which consists of her and her nine
children the social media influencer
revealed on tuesday
that this guy with a 400 million dollar
net worth he's kind of a short guy
and um james no george campbell no the
guy the guy with the 400 million dollar
net worth that would not be james and
that would not be george campbell oh
that's my bad yeah his name is shaq she
might have heard of him shaquille o'neal
never heard of him yeah so
he took the collins family out to dinner
babes chicken
the next day took him the mercedes-benz
dealer and bought them a 15 passenger
band
after buying the car they went out to
dinner again at the rainforest cafe
where he dropped another thousand bucks
with the tip on the waitress just the
tip to the waitress alone
and after dinner he uh noticed uh
chris's husband's truck which was uh the
heat and air and the air conditioning
was falling apart
you know it was a dumpy truck and so he
took him down the ford dealership and
bought him a new truck
who is shaq because you know i could i
see like elvis i get chocolate people
cars i get choked up on these things man
this is amazing
because like let's not blow pet that a
thousand dollars for that waitress at
the rainforest cafe changed her
entire i mean
that's huge yeah don't drive past a 15
passenger mercedes van okay that's just
a little different than a thousand
dollars too but oh my gosh oh and i saw
this one
he dropped less than i don't know what
that van cost but he dropped 150 000
probably
and he made he has a 400 million net
worth so that is like
you know it's a very very small
percentage ratio of his world
he's not broke from doing it
um i saw this one the guy was in there
and he was trying to buy a wedding i
mean engagement ring for his wife and
jack just happened to be in the same
jewelry store shopping for something
and the guy was kind of getting nervous
and he was trying to he was paying and
shaq walked over and just handed his car
to the the person at the counter and pat
him on the back and said congratulations
my man can you imagine being able to
just do that for somebody just being in
there to buy something for your wife or
your sister and all of a sudden being
able to
i mean come on man it was such an
amazing thing
bought a house for this young man who
was paralyzed by a stray bullet
yeah these evil rich people need to stop
this that is ridiculous that's just
ridiculous that your your evilness needs
to stop that's right evilness that's a
word right
evil in action
shaq you're just you're destroying the
reputation of the evil rich people come
on man with that gen with that
outrageous generosity come on man
wow that's pretty cool i did not know he
had this
uh
knack for random
generosity like this that's very well
played but a thousand places and he's so
he's so subtle because he fills up the
whole room when he walks in it so it's
no way there's no way you can be shaq
and be
invisible but can i tell you he does it
i saw him i saw a clip of this with the
guy at the zales and it was the most
quiet it wasn't a big hey look what i'm
doing he gently handed the guy and said
this one's on me and it's in his big
deep voice and he pat the guy on the
back and he said congratulations brother
and walked off and it was not a
it was i've been blessed so i can be a
blessing right it's that sense of i've
been given so much and i'm just going to
bless these families and and of course
he's got these big you know things that
he gives 500 kids clothes here but
but it's just that kind of generosity
man that i can get choked up thinking
about it because it's so cool
um and thinking how cool would be on the
other end of this to be able to just do
that well the thing is with our you know
generous people make your eyes leak yeah
and they just we all love them nobody
hate nobody hates generous people no
but but you know you can't do that
if you're broke
if you're broke
[Music]
and you're bitching about rich people on
your iphone that you have payments on
you can't do that because you're broke
so hello just just just a little
heads up there
you know bitching about rich people on
your 800 dollar iphone thanks for
pulling the thousand dollar iphone huge
yeah james you just you just you're just
showing people how rich people really
are i'm
this is i don't know we can continue
this level of expose
it's just emotionally distressing to
you know to just
let people see how people really are out
there
because generosity is all over the place
man
wow hey uh
jacon is it jaken jaken is with us in
modesto
let's see if i can get it on there there
it is jacob how are you man
what's up good how are you guys doing
today great how can we help
good um
so
about two and a half years ago found you
[Music]
me and my wife are about a month away
from being done with baby step two yay
and then um
shortly after that once three is done i
have a
six-year-old a four-year-old
and a seven-month-old all three girls
you are in it my brother you're in it
yes yes
but i was thinking about 529s in their
future
and from what i understand is you can
use a 529 for any family member
so is it better to
get them three individual
529s or
would a
single 529 that i could just load up
earn more money faster
nah it won't matter
three with a thousand dollars in them
each will grow at the same exact rate as
one with three thousand dollars so it
won't matter i would open three so that
you've got an individual accounting for
each kid
and you can tell what's going on sit
down with your smartvestor pro they can
help you get that open
but there's no change compound interest
is compound interest it works the same
way because it's always dealing with the
total amount of money you have in other
words if you take
three one thousand dollar deposits into
exactly the same mutual fund with three
different account numbers or you put
three thousand dollars in that mutual
fund with one account number it will
grow at exactly the same rate
exactly the same rate the fact that it's
separated does not change the math at
all on the total now it does change the
math on the thousand obviously because
it's not three thousand it's one
thousand but but the uh but on the total
it doesn't change it at all you'll be
just fine and and you it's better to be
able to look at the kids and go hey come
over to the screen this is your 529
and we're starting to talk about your
future and how we feel about education
with you
and where you are going to go to school
and that's a different individual
instead of like okay family let's have a
meeting and talk about the the group for
the community 401k
for dan i'm sorry
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five as we talk about your life
and your money okay married folks
imagine never having another money
argument what would that be like
considering it's the number one thing
people divorce over money fights money
problems the number one thing they fight
about money fights money problems
when you get on the same page with money
it's like there's not a lot left to
fight about i mean you got to really
work at it after that so
it changes your marriage it changes your
finances it increases the probability of
success in your marriage and in your
money
hello sounds like a good plan how do
people learn how to do that in financial
peace university we've been teaching
people to do that for many decades
almost 10 million people have been
through this class
and many many many of them say saved or
enhanced
or changed their marriage in a good way
so to join a financial peace university
class you can take a free trial at
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's
com
ramseysolutions.com
fpu
oh by the way we'll also teach you how
to get out of debt and become wealthy
which is actually what the class is
about
but in the process it changes your
marriage ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu phil's in minneapolis hey phil
what's up
hey dave and john uh yeah i'm calling
from minnesota i got a bit of a weird
question that i've never heard answered
before i am a realtor so i work on
commission
my wife and i are in baby step four five
and six she works for the school
district and we front loaded our iras
roth iras in november and we just did
our taxes and
turns out we made over the threshold
so we can no longer put in the six
thousand dollars total so you made over
two hundred thousand household income
yep just barely
but yes we did and so now we gotta pull
money out of the ira and now
they're down about 10 from when we put
them in so obviously that's going to be
money loss they're
trying to figure out how to get them
back into
an investment because everybody from
what i'm hearing is saying that you've
got to pull them back out and put them
in the money market
uh you don't have to put them in a money
market that's not required but you have
to pull them out you have to liquidate
these because they're traditional iras
right
no they're rough they're roths
they're roth iras
yeah for my tax pro he says you you
can't do that and then my my investment
dividers is actually an elp
and she said yeah that that sounds right
yeah you have to pull it yeah
but but what you can do and your smart
investor pro should be able to help you
with this part what you can do is do
what's called a back door roth
and if you you unfollowed you unfollowed
your taxes i'm sorry
she said that wasn't an option because
what we did is we have so i have a
company that pays basically i have an s
corp and
so i get my salary out of there
so my business taxes are already done
that's already filed our personal is not
done yet
um she said you we weren't able to do a
backdoor ross
and i'm not quite sure why she leans
towards doing a sep
but i can't do a step for 2021 now that
it's 20 22. yeah you got to pull the
money out that's settled what you do
with it is not settled um
i i think there's a bunch of different
conversations going on and maybe they're
getting confused here uh i don't hear
any reason you can't do a backdoor roth
a backdoor roth is a personal move it's
not a business move if you haven't filed
your taxes for 2021 you can still do a
backdoor roth here's how it works unless
they can give you a good reason that you
can't do it and i don't know what that
would be do you have a huge amount of
money in a traditional already
no less than 100. okay then you you
should be able to do this so hit your
smart investor pro again and tell him
dave said he thinks you can so really
look into it because here's what i think
and i might there may be a detail of
your situation i don't have yet or i may
be missing something in this
conversation this but i don't think i am
if you can do a back door roth after you
pull this money out which you have to
pull it out here's what you would do
before you file your taxes you would
open an after-tax
traditional
not a pretext okay
and immediately 30 seconds later roll it
into a roth
okay so i can just roll it from
traditional to roth yeah it from an
after tax
traditional
not a before tax okay it's an unusual
okay traditional okay but it's an
after-tax traditional and you roll it
then into
a roth instantaneously and you could do
it all with the same mutual fund that
you're in and you know you could do it
with the money that's left that you have
to pull out you don't even have to go
all the way to 6 000 but if you want to
add a little to it you can do that
i know you can still do them i just did
one the other day
good so i mean i know i know in general
it's possible but i but now is there a
way to roll the current money that
you've got over into that i don't think
so i think you just got to pull it out
now i'm sitting here with some cash in
my hand from this ira that i overfunded
and now i'm gonna do a back door roth
instead and you probably are just gonna
do back door roths as long as they exist
for the rest of your life because you're
probably gonna make over 200 from now on
thank god that's wonderful i'm proud for
you
peyton is in portland maine hi peyton
welcome to the ramsey show
hey john uh how are you guys great man
what's up
so i have a little bit of a relationship
question with my about my parents i'm
20. um i just finished school i work
full time i'm on baby step 2 right now
so i'm paying off my student loans
and my car i just i'm almost done paying
off my car right now i had an account
statement on my counter and my parents
saw and they seemed they seemed almost
disappointed that i'm paying off the
debt because they really they're really
worried about my credit score but you
know i don't know how to
explain to them like the plan i'm doing
with you guys i've tried to before but
it just doesn't seem to register and
they were really it seemed like they
were really disappointed i just didn't
know how to go about that it kind of
took me back
um i know in my heart i'm doing the
right thing but i want to be able to
honor them
with doing this because they think i'm
being irresponsible so i'm just not sure
how to go about dealing with that
situation with them how old are you now
did you say 20 20 uh 20. all right do
you live at home
i do yes okay i'm going to give you a
gift well this is going to give you a
gift and it's going to be a little bit
complicated because you live at home but
i want you to keep this near and dear to
your heart okay
they don't get a vote
you're out of college you got a job
you're making a living now they do get a
vote because right now you live in their
house and so if they tell you to be home
at nine o'clock and to fold your socks a
certain way you live in their house and
they can do that but when it comes to
how i'm taking care of my money my dad
has opinions
which is fine well and good but me and
my wife make decisions financially for
my household
and you're making your own money you're
making your own job you're paying off
your own debts and they can tell you hey
we think you should do this and really
care about this loan and what
thank you so much for your wisdom i'm
really grateful i have a relative that
tells me how i should vote and they're
wrong
[Laughter]
so they don't get a vote okay and what
you what you if man if you can learn
this at 20 that people who love you and
care about you are going to give you bad
advice and they still love you and care
about you and y'all gonna be able to
move on with your day i mean if you
could
i didn't figure that out until i was
like 35. so if you can figure that at 20
the rest of your life is going to be
good because this is going to continue
to happen that way okay yeah yeah and so
here's the thing um
you know mom and dad i don't want to
disappoint you guys and i know that you
don't understand what i'm doing here
uh and i love you and i respect you uh
but i've actually do have a system and i
actually am working a plan
uh
from some reading and some studying that
i've been doing on how to handle money
and it's working for me
so i know you don't understand but it's
okay i'm gonna be okay
and if
i'll be happy to talk to you about it
but i'm but you you need to separate the
part where you need their you
emotionally need their approval
to be an adult that's what john's saying
okay
a great gift man i sometimes when i'm
trying to explain a hard concept you
know if i'm talking to somebody and i'm
i i just don't have the words to explain
it i'll hand them a book and say this
guy or a podcast this guy does it better
than me she this this brilliant doctor
she writes this better than i can
explain it right now and so maybe if you
say hey if you don't fully understand i
get it here's a copy of total money
makeover read this this guy there's a
better job experience maybe steps me in
here that's right just do a better job
of explaining it to me yeah that's not a
bad thing to do either and go this is
what i'm doing and if this helps you it
might be interesting to you it might not
you may just want to stand back and not
agree and that's okay too you can do
whatever you want to do i'm just i'm
going to be going forward with this
thing
and it's a smile and a gentle word no
faith
no there's no
acid in the air no passive aggressive in
the
question or the statement
just
be there
this is the ramsey
[Music]
left
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage sherman and christina
are with us welcome guys how are you
thank you for having us we're great
we're great we're excited to be here
we're honored to have you where do you
live in gainesville florida oh very cool
well good to have you thanks for joining
us all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free scream yes all the way to
nashville cool how much did you pay off
two hundred and three thousand dollars
in 27 months way to go oh
wow
and your range of income during that
time started right around a hundred
thousand dollars and up to about
15. wow sherman did you go back to work
that's a pretty big jump man
i had to get to work that's right
what do you guys do for a living we own
a gym in gainesville florida dynasty
crossfit then we also own a marketing
firm
framework now okay you own a marketing
firm too so what drove this income to
double in two years i mean two and a
half years yeah um the marketing firm
sort of took off the gym was our main
thing for years and then we started the
marketing firm so you know both of them
just sort of continue to rise as we get
more focused on paying off the debt
finally how that works funny how that
works yeah i need some money i wonder
where i can find something yeah that's
good very good way to go you guys what
kind of debt was the 203 um
mostly student loans his student loans
mainly student loans i guess they were
my student loans apparently
apparently that's the worst [ __ ] i
thought they were ours
so mainly student loans uh we paid off a
car we cashflowed a few things but
mainly the bulk of it was student loans
wow undergrad graduate school so yeah
what's your degree in um i got a
undergrad
degree in psychology then i went to a
master's program in biomedical science
but not really utilizing those now so i
don't know jim
yeah yeah
here we are if you want to stretch it
probably probably inform some of the
decisions maybe will you realize it or
not way to go guys yes good job very fun
so what started this journey uh 27
months ago this ramsey idea yeah so
we've known about ramsey for the entire
time we've been married when we first
got married we took um fpu
and that sort of gave us sort of gave us
the foundations to not go into more debt
but
we weren't ready to be serious about it
for a few years a couple years ago so
you're flunked yeah yeah okay
i want to say we we we definitely had
you got to see i think we had them
complete tonight i guess yeah
we just didn't want to accrue more debt
so we were more aware of you know not
you know working side hustles working
multiple jobs especially even during
pregnancies
we were very much aware like this this
is something we owe and we need to pay
it back we just didn't know how god
would multiply our income in such a way
that from what we were making to what
we're making now um until about two
years ago when we heard a word from the
lord um and we're like you know our
obedience he he has to take care of it
so this is where we're at we're only
making a hundred grand it seems like an
enormous mountain and we're just going
to have to chip away at it and at some
point people aren't away at it and also
on the income took off the income
he's faithful he his provision is
amazing and it's through that that um
all these opportunities started becoming
about and we were able to tip even
further amen and amen
way to go you guys cool
very cool so
all right so you you
you get re-energized yes years later
after fpu 27 months ago you say all
right game on
what was the conversation do you
remember
that i mean you said you got a word from
the lord right so there was a a moment
in time that something just kind of was
a wake-up call there's a milestone there
where it turned right
yeah definitely so it's funny because we
were actually up here visiting our good
friends the coaliots up here um in
nashville and i thought i had seen you
all out here yeah we've been here
numerous times well you're pretty people
you're hard to forget yeah i mean ladies
tell me that so thank you dave
listen i'm not standing by you in the
photos all i'm saying that's all i'm
saying um so we were up here and
up here on vacation and those student
loan people they called me
and that just
while you're in a lobby no while we were
up here on vacation oh in nashville and
that just put that i don't know why that
just turned the knife turned the knife
and i was like no more
yeah
yeah yeah
all right so you go and sit down you sit
down with christine and say so uh for
the next couple years we're not gonna
buy anything yeah um we're gonna have to
duct tape the kids to the floor because
they might have to go to like we're
gonna get after this were you all in
yeah yeah she was all lit
i've always been
but she was definitely all in she was
like if you want to do it let's do it i
was just like all right i guess i really
have to do it and i started hoping she
would say yeah maybe she was like all
right let's do it because i feel like if
your cob i got to do something at that
point it's a conviction and it's just
through our obedience that he's going to
um
trip you're walking around out here in
the lobby yeah yeah that'll get on you
too yeah absolutely and we did that
intentionally i remember saying well we
have to go and it kept us um it's a
drive from there's the picture all right
i'm not i wasn't losing my mind all
right
i'm in the picture yeah
it kept us motivated it's something that
that um
once god calls us to do something i mean
it's easy for us we don't have there is
no no like
the consequences there is no reward to
disobedience put me in coach
this is what we have to do and then now
we get to watch him
um
provide and make a way so it's it was
easier for me because it's like all
right god hands off you work your your
um your miracles and your whatever you
need us to do we're in we're in well i
mean
you doubled your income during this time
so yeah he was obviously showing off he
did he showed up and showed up and i
know i know in a big way florida's been
been
different in throughout this but you got
to say that 24 months ago running a gym
also in the world your heart's going to
start being a little bit faster right
absolutely you were absolutely you were
exposed right now we did but we always
had peace we had a word like that that's
it that's all we needed so our faith was
strong enough and our children are
amazing like they're
they're gung-ho about anything too and
when we all sat down as a family we came
up with a budget there was no going back
there i mean we were all in and we knew
that god was we knew it would be hard
but i knew that um it would be rewarding
as well so we focused more on serving
others and doing what we could for other
people
taught a fpu class during that time just
to test wow stay focused oh thank you
yeah what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
i would say you have to have a budget
you have to stick to the budget and
for me one of the biggest things is your
spouse
if you're married your spouse needs to
be
on board with you because that made it
even easier for me like christina stays
at home
doesn't work outside at home she
homeschools our three kids so it could
have been easy for her to say i'm you
know i'm not going to be on board with
this i got to take care of these kids
but she was like if you want to do it
i'm totally on board so having a budget
and then having a spouse that fully
supported me that made it
that much better and i think it for me
it was easier because um not easy but it
was a lot easier to understand this is
not our money we have to pay it back
i'm not mad at the student loan people
we he signed the paperwork i mean we owe
them so it's
you know it is a commitment and back to
it's your money no no no it's not me
it's not that it's something we we
wanted to and in marriage that was one
thing he he always you know brought up
was hey i have this mountain of debt you
know from school and i'm like it's ours
it really is and that's that honestly
was the point i was trying to get to
yeah you're very very healthy we're
probably fun at it but very good very
well said that's very well done we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure
now that outrageous generosity so you're
on track to be able to do all of that
what are the kiddos names and ages
we have judah here he's eight we have
ariana she's 10 we have caden he's 13.
all right beautiful beautiful
good-looking family well done you guys
we're proud of y'all good work you're
amazing people well done 203 000 paid
off in 27 months making a hundred to 215
sherman christina cayden ariana and
judah count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream here we go in three
two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
that's how it's done man
that's how it's done
27 months later
game on that is that is a different kind
of game off when you just decide
something
that's when you draw the line of sin i'm
with my family you will never call me
again i'm done with you i'm done don't
you're bothering me i'm out the
borrower's slave the lender and i don't
like it anymore i'm out this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at 825-5225
we're talking about your relationships
your mental health
anxiety we're talking about
jobs and careers we're talking about
money marriage
kids life it shows up right here on the
ramsey show
andrew's with us andrew is in saint
petersburg florida hi andrew what's up
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
well um thanks for taking my call i've
been looking forward to doing this for a
while now um i have
a large question but i'm hoping you can
help me out um
i work right now in insurance i make
pretty good money um i'm bored you're
going to ask me how much i don't know
exactly because i haven't looked at my
last years but i know it's well above
120 it's probably about 150 for the year
okay um i love the company i work for i
love the people i work with it's you
know it's been a blessing
and i've been here for about four years
now
however i did start a business uh
renting electric bikes here in saint
pete florida and um it's obviously
something i'm a little bit more
passionate about something i love to do
and
i'm just really nervous right now it's
kind of part time if you will um i run
it with my cousin so we kind of balance
out the workload and then my brother is
like our full-time employee so it's sort
of passive income with me working it on
the weekends
um and i've got i'm just trying to
figure out kind of how or if i should
transition i never want to give up my
book of business with what i do now in
insurance because i've worked really
hard for it and now it's at a really
good point where i could you know go to
more of a part-time place and start
focusing more on just renewing my book
and not so much on new sales
but it's still scary to like make the
jump you know from going to
being sales sales you know new business
every month and renewing to kind of
shifting my focus
onto
this business um what'd you make on the
business
what's that how much you make on the
business last year
oh well it's it's new it's all right we
haven't given many money
no
no i mean i mean honestly no i don't
need to quit doing anything do you make
money
yeah that's true
um it's definitely not as much as yeah
i'm making an hour you're not making any
money
so it's definitely not as much
yeah
i wouldn't have any problem with you
taking a pay cut if it's something you
really want to do and you enjoyed your
life but you right now you're you're
making zero
yeah so you got to get this you got to
get the business profitable and i want
to see it i want to see it putting 100
000 in your pocket
right yeah because it's not i mean it
does make maybe a few thousand a month
but definitely not you know in your
pocket
in your pocket
after everybody's paid
after the brothers paid after you split
with your cousin
buying new bikes and they replaced the
ones that the drunks tore up
and all the stuff you have to do in that
business
right right
now once you get it to a hundred here's
the second thing you need to do before
you make the jump but don't even talk to
it don't talk about quitting your other
thing until you get this up to 100.
you're kind of coasting around in this
conversation and i need you to for your
sake i want you to be very very precise
because if you don't you're going to
make a mistake so when you get to 100 i
see two problems with this business
okay
that that is that threatens the future
of it
one is competition
as soon as bird put a scooter on the
street three other people did
and if you were all in on bird scooters
you'd be screwed right now
because the competition would have run
you out of business
and electric bikes are another version
of bird scooters okay
the second thing is this is a very
technology driven
app-driven
social type movement
product
and
if it suddenly goes if it's no longer
it's it's it works right now because
it's cool
it's cool it's it's in vogue it's the
cool thing to do
in five years it's not going to be the
cool thing to do anymore
so in addition to
having a plan of how you're going to
survive the competition you need a plan
on how you're going to
uh
add other types of product lines that do
not falter as quickly when they're not
cool anymore
when you have a fad
product
when the fad's over your business is
over if you don't have another product
and so in addition to
electric bicycles
uh
you know i mean if you think about look
back five years five years ago no bird
scooters no electric bicycles
they just showed up boy i mean this is
it
and so uh something else is going to
show up they'll go wages as fast and
it's just it's not going to be cool
that's what i mean by cool it's
something you're on a fad product line
something in a high rate of change
industry you got to have a plan for
where you're going next
not i'm going to do this for 20 years
with like bicycles because 20 years from
now you won't be doing electric bicycles
i promise you and this is a strange call
uh andrew because 99 of time someone
calls it's i'm a nurse and i cannot do
this anymore i'm a teacher and i cannot
i'm a police officer and i can't
the way you talked about your insurance
company
you like it you love these people and so
here's the thing there is this weird
pressure going along around people who
are 25 and younger if you're working for
a company that somehow you're failing
that if you're not quitting your job to
go do your quote-unquote own thing um
that you're somehow less than
i i call that's not true bullcrap on
that if you love your job you're making
150 grand and you're good at it and
you're building it there is nothing
wrong with staying there and crushing
and hustling it there with with your
company man so the third option
is
uh
stay in the job permanently
do the things i'm talking about with the
business
and get the business so profitable that
you just staff it
and run it and you're an absentee
investor that's what i like you're not
an operator hire some high school kids
to run it for well he's got he's got the
brother in there starting it right the
first full-time employee so we can put
some other employees in there as the
profitability goes and let's run that up
but you still are going to have to look
at how you're going to double and triple
the revenues you're still going to have
to look at how you can diversify your
product lines because you're in a very
i don't know i don't know the other
proper word to use other than fad you're
in a very v in vogue product in a high
rate of change industry and you're gonna
get your head taken off with that
because you're gonna just wake up one
more it's gonna be over and and and
you're sitting there with a whole bunch
of bikes 75 electric electronic bikes
yeah i mean it's just that's going to be
a problem and it's not going to be
happening tomorrow it's not going to
happen next year but five years from now
i mean you know you may be using
maybe using holograms to book the deal
you know i mean i don't know
so uh all right rose is in tampa hi rose
how are you
thank you for taking my call dave and dr
john
sure what's up can you hear me okay yeah
so my question is i have i currently
have two rental properties and one of
them will be sold this summer so that'll
be out of question but i have a town
home
that i it's empty right now tenants just
moved out um and i'm wondering if i
should sell it or keep it long-term
what's it worth
about 217. is it paid for
i have 45 000 which i'm going to be
paying off at the end of this so let's
pile up 250 000 let's pretend you don't
own the town home
and i just put 250 000 cash stacked up
in the middle of your dining room table
what type of investment are you going to
do with that are you going to buy rental
property
are you going to invest in mutual funds
what are you going to do with that
everything else i have is in the market
and so for me real estate was this
is just not having 100 of everything in
the market do you want to buy with your
250 000 in the middle of the table
do you want to buy a piece of real
estate
i'm unsure that's what i'm calling okay
there's not a wrong answer
yes is the right answer and no is the
right answer um because it's what you
want to do real estate is not a bad
investment
this is not the perfect time to sell if
you should be holding i'm not selling
mine i got a bunch of it and i'm keeping
it
and i'm just smiling that it's worth a
lot more and that the rents are going up
on all of it i'm just smiling
uh but if uh
if you are sick and tired of real estate
you there's no law that says you have to
own real estate
so you can sell it
but if you would buy more real estate
with that money then you would keep this
if you would sell it if you would not
buy more real estate with it then you
would sell this that's how i help
analyze it help me walk through the
emotions in my situations
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
baloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today
as we answer your questions about your
money your relationships your mental
health your anxiety your job your career
anything having to do with your life
marriage parenting it's all here it's
called the ramsay show the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five joe is in st louis hi joe how are
you
hey dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up i i called you
i discovered you about seven years ago
on the radio
and i'm 71 years old
and my finances all my life been up and
down
and i can tell you that i paid my
mortgage off yesterday and i'm debt-free
never too late it's never too late to
learn
and i learn from you
and that's what i called you about i'm a
little nervous now but uh
i took 99 of your advice
i didn't do it all but i took 99
and i want to tell you and other people
out there it's never too late
yeah you're starting here you start in
your mid 60s and you paid off your house
when you're 71. i'm so proud of you 71 i
paid it off yesterday that's awesome
what's this house worth
oh about 150. look at you with a paid
for house
i've been up and down in finances and
income all my life
and i live pay
paycheck to paycheck until you
and i just wanted to say thank you well
thank you you're an inspiration sir
i you're i appreciate it honored you
called never too late and it's never too
late so what's your house worth you
think
you said 150 150 you said 150 150 that
was yeah yeah and and
you still working
yeah i'm retired but i work part-time
okay and uh
but my finances have never been the way
they are now
just because of you so you not only got
to paid for a house that has gives you a
sense of peace
but more than that or more importantly
you have a sense that you're under
control
oh yes i've never been under control in
all these years with my finances
they've been up and down i had a lot of
things i lost a lot of things
but
they are now right now you are now i'm
sitting on the banks of the mississippi
river
and i'm looking at bald eagles flying up
and down the river right now
life is good much better than that thank
you for your gratitude my brother that's
awesome that's just beautiful just
beautiful thank you so much
robert is in modesto california hi
robert welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um
actually i want to listen to your
podcast maybe three times since we
started this week wow
i actually got you to talk to you
welcome to the gang man
welcome in brother tell me about two
months now that i needed to listen to
you
um we're kind of your wife right if
we're on the same page here she's 48 i'm
54 i make 100 000 a year
just over that um as a paramedic um here
in california
and we are three hundred thousand
dollars up on equity in our house
i have about 600 000 and 401k
75 000 in cars and um
about 30 000 in debt that's a student
loan and a credit card
my wife wants to go to a larger home
because we are
small at home four of us here 19 year
old 15 year old me and the wife and
we're just running out of room here she
wants to go to a larger home to me
that's a larger payment
you know a little less stress
on us space-wise a little more stress on
his financial life she advises if i do
the ramsey thing
then uh you know
we'll find the money type of stuff is it
a bad idea to go to a larger home
i'm sorry the last part about the ramsey
thing say that again
she says if we start doing the seven
steps and doing the ramsey method that
it um it'll all work out that the
the the more payment is not going to be
that big a deal because we'll find the
money somewhere else the baby steps
aren't pixie does brother yeah the
problem is the problem is that the the
ramsey thing is going to cause you to
not go get a home because you have other
debt you've got to clean up before you
talk about doing that
30 000 worth
okay you don't move up and home until
you get that mess cleaned up
the consumer debt that you've got
right and you're running out of room in
your house you got a 19 year old that
[ __ ] will probably be taken off soon you
got a 15 year old that's just got a
couple of years left i mean this sounds
rather relatively temporary right
yeah you were running out of room 10
years ago yeah now you're not running
out of room now they're running out of
the house
yeah we've been in this house for 20
years that sounds like more of the issue
than the space issue because y'all want
to go do something i don't mind you all
moving to a different home even a more
expensive home i would not do it because
you're running out of room because your
kids are about to leave in an eye blink
uh i'm with john on that i would not do
it until you get your debts paid off
that you have other than the house
and then that would entail that you are
working the ramsey baby steps that you
have your fully funded emergency fund
your debt-free accept the house and then
when you make the move on the house your
payment is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed rate
and then we plan to work extra and pay
that house off sooner than 15 years
because that's what people that become
millionaires do
that would be the ramsey plan
not um we're gonna move into a higher
house payment and then we're gonna start
seven baby steps and that'll make it
work out that's right no lady that is
not the ramsey plan i'm sorry and robert
make sure that you don't have 300 000 of
imaginary equity burning a hole in your
pocket yeah a lot of folks feel like oh
my house is worth this so now i have to
go x y and z because when you sell in an
up market you also have to buy in enough
that's right that's right
so hang up
man i'm a hang on to it man that that
itch might not be scratched by just
spending that money that you don't have
yeah so i i
i think we need to redefine why we're
moving yep you can't be the two kids
because they're not going to be there
and say i've lived here for 20 years
i'll do something else that's great
that's okay it's wonderful that's okay
that's not a bad thing but we're running
out of room that you should have said
that 10 years ago that's right because
you were out of room then
um if you were going to use that one it
sounds like y'all if y'all feel like you
have a 300 000 blank check and you don't
that's the part i'm worried about
i think she went out to some open houses
and saw some nice cabinets in the
kitchen no
that's never happened at our house
oh geez
it's like i'm just gonna go to the car
lot and look at them that's right at the
bentley lot i'm just gonna go
drive the drive the maserati that's all
i'm gonna do look at it yeah i'm just
gonna drive the new raptor
would you look at that screen
i don't know how people make it without
a screen that size yeah it's uh we all
do this is what we're saying not just
your wife but i think she
uh
i i might accuse sharon ramsey of doing
similar things like she goes to some
friend's house or to an open house i'm
just going to stop by and look i want
wanna see what people are doing in
kitchens these days suddenly the ramseys
are like oh
or we're tearing the whole freaking
kitchen out yeah and which usually means
that 24 months after we do that we're
moving then you're moving but yeah so
[Music]
this is a this is an ailment that is
common to lots of households robert this
is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
well real estate market's pretty hyped
up right now if you hadn't noticed the
buyers are feeling the pressure to buy
the sellers are going i can get a lot of
money it's not amateur hour out there
don't get me wrong rates probably won't
get any cheaper than they are right now
doesn't give you a reason to green light
stupid okay
you don't necessarily need to get caught
up in the hype the flow the tidal wave
whatever you want to call this
or you don't have to get caught up in
offering way over asking price because
you're desperate don't get caught up in
the hype
you know you got to get your head out of
the craziness and you get a second look
at the facts are you debt free do you
have a down payment
are you putting it on a 15 year where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
only if the answer is a big fat yes or
you're ready to buy but if you're ready
to buy
we can help you with this
once you've answered the questions it's
time to look at some old cold hard
numbers
you can use our free mortgage calculator
to see exactly
what your home ownership options are
based on your budget
real ramsey stuff
so go to ramseysolutions.com
click free tools
use the mortgage calculator it'll tell
you what to do
ramseysolutions.com
click free
that's a keyword right there free
tools our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time a great american company blinds.com
always use ramsey as a promo code it's
magic it'll get you the best deal all
right today's question comes from megan
in wyoming megan writes i've been
married for 14 years and due to anger
issues i need to leave my marriage and
take our children with me
i'm struggling with how to pay bills and
find a place for him to live
i'm in the first year of a great career
but my pay is not yet consistent i earn
fifty thousand dollars a year and my
husband makes about the same amount
i feel like i need to be financially
responsible for the house we own
together and an apartment for him to
move to when we separate
how should i plan financially to be
ready to leave him
if you have come to a situation in your
marriage where you are not safe
and you decide to terminate your
marriage because somebody has made it
your home and your relationship
inhabitable you are not responsible for
finding them a place to live
that's their responsibility
yeah
this is hard man buddy of mine that does
divorce recovery many many years ago
here on the air said divorce changes a
marriage into a business transaction
that's right
this is no longer about you taking care
of him
far
from your need to take care of him
you're having to end this because he
can't control himself
so his rage and anger issues so
um
time for the mad little boy to grow up
and get his own apartment in his own
place that's right yeah
so um yeah you know
that feels um
like an abuse abused language exactly
what it sounds like like i need to take
care i need to make sure he's okay
to keep him calm right while i do this
big big thing yeah just so i go over
here and do all the adult stuff i need
to keep him calm that's right
and uh and or uh
i'm worried about him
even i love him even though i don't you
know and that that's all that's all
abused language right
abuse so megan you need to get yourself
a excellent attorney who will walk
things through with you you need to get
a couple of women in your life that will
walk through this with you
and well you can bounce decisions off of
get a good pastor a counselor that can
walk with you you're going to need some
support here and you trying to make sure
all the teas are crossed and eyes are
dotted including where he's going to
live and how he's going to eat and what
kind of car he's going to drive you're
taking on too much taking on too much
when someone leaves
and we you call them the ex-husband
it's because they're not the husband
anymore that's right
yeah that's why we call them ex your
responsibility for how they choose to
live and eat is no more exes used to be
not anymore right your problem now over
that's what that means so it's a is a
clear line there of your responsibility
like when he walks out the door with the
suitcases that line is following him
correct and it's going to follow him as
he drives down the street like some kind
of a bad progressive commercial or
something right but
yeah and and that's okay that that
that's where your line of responsibility
ends is right at his butt as he leaves
so let's take him out of the picture
mom needs to just simply circle back to
the baby steps right now she's got her
and i don't she doesn't see how many
kids let's say she's got two kids and
she makes 50 000 then she needs to say
can i afford this home on 50 000 can i
afford the four walls bills and
transportation and food can i take care
of my
necessities right as i make this this
transition and i would even go as far to
say
you need to take care of yourself if
you're not safe whether or not you can
afford that house it might mean that you
got to move to an apartment for a season
and the house gets sold that's right
yeah
so here's the last part of that that you
know that's where i was going to is
i'm going to make the number up but i'm
not far off
as i have worked over 30 years with
these situations where
there's a divorce mom wants the lady
wants to stay in the home
in this case she makes the same amount
of money usually she makes less
statistically right okay not saying
that's right or wrong that is wrong
if she does less she should make less
but if she does the same she ought to
make the same
so uh anyway she's got the same amount
of money here but the household income
is getting ready to be cut in half
i need to the kid's world is rocked
because of the marriage ending
dad's not going to be in the house the
kid's world is rocked the kid's world is
rocked and i need to provide a safe
place
stable environment for my kids i don't
want to give them any more change than
the change that's already occurring
so i don't want their school or their
friends or their bedroom to be upset so
i'm gonna keep a house i can't afford
right
and i gotta tell you that happens a lot
it does and instead of you getting a
fresh start after this
you're starting in the hole after this
but now it may not be the case and maybe
you can afford the house it's okay but
john's advice there to where you say i'm
gonna really look at the budget and
decide can i afford on my income to keep
this house otherwise the house needs to
be sold as part of the divorce here's
what it is it's i want to prop up this
picture of family life yep and i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna cut him out of it
but i'm gonna keep this picture propped
up and you need to know when you file
for divorce everything's different yeah
that old picture is oh and those kids
are not better off in a house you can't
afford in your stress in their old
bedrooms right than they are in a brand
new apartment that you can afford
uh and your stress level is way down and
you can be emotionally present for them
because you're not crying over the bills
after that environment can help them
actually make a psychological shift that
now we're in a new world that's actually
helpful sometimes yeah the visual of
that's not bad that's right yeah
so it's not it's not always the best
thing to keep the house yeah it's not
sometimes it's okay
most of the time it's not
it's not so you're not telling you have
to sell it but i'm telling you got to
put it on the table that that's a
possibility
and i'm heartbroken for you megan yeah
that's awful [ __ ] about you
awful awful awful awful open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
um shane on facebook says can you
distinguish the difference between
enabling and helping
yeah uh
helping helps enabling enables i i think
wow did you go to school for that yeah
that was that was an entire class i paid
for 900 an hour um i if i'm helping
somebody i am
walking alongside them as they get
better they improve their life they get
closer towards their goal enabling makes
me feel better not them right so
enabling helps me think i'm doing
something it makes me feel like i'm
doing something to support somebody
they're actually not been not only not
benefiting from it their life is getting
worse because of my my participation in
their life
enabling is a drunk gets a drink right
he feels better and you think you helped
but you didn't you harmed
helping is i'm going to pick you up and
go to a.a with you the first meeting
helping is i'm going to embrace
suck with you and we're going to go
together and get this thing
messed straightened up and so um but
enabling
makes feels like you did something you
called it helping
but it
allowed the person to continue in the
destructive behavior
enablings for me helpings for them maybe
that's the best way to say that enabling
is helping is often labeled as tough
love
enabling is often labeled as love by the
person who's getting the gift that
shouldn't be getting it
that's good all right i feel better now
i do too
i feel totally helped i was i wasn't
enabled at all i feel enabled i wasn't
enabled but it didn't happen not right
here on the air this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
in the lobby of ramsey solutions right
here on the debt-free stage is none
other than gary and jill welcome you
guys thank you we're excited to be here
well we're honored to have you where do
you guys live
um so we're from alexandria virginia
right outside of dc yeah welcome to
nashville we uh we brought the sun out
for you today thank you for that it's a
nice day out there if you're a duck
in this rain but uh oh my gosh welcome
so uh down there to do a debt-free
scream how much you paid off
658 thousand three hundred and eleven
dollars wow
how long did this take six years all
right i love this
and your range of income during this
time
142 thousand
and 272 000 cool what do you guys do for
a living
i'm so i'm a teacher
and i'm a certified public accountant
and owner of steward solutions ah very
good very good so what do you what do
you teach i teach first grade um with
dcps in right in washington dc yeah good
for you yeah very cool you are you've
had a boring last 24 months i've been
really bored
wow well the kids have never been the
problem it was always the parents and
the administrators that's the only
people we've ever had to worry about
yeah way to go you guys very cool all
right i'm guessing with these numbers
six hundred fifty eight thousand and six
years you paid off your house
i wish
no they're in dc six six hundred
thousand it's a garage apartment right
yeah you can't buy much with 615 dc i
know i know but i thought oh no what did
you
what did you do richard what did you do
i mean we had awards
a lot of credit on our home
um 218 000 was credit cards
162 000 was student loans
and then just a bunch of like
miscellaneous debts
you're a cpa
you 200 000
in credit card debt
it was bad explain this to america
we were having a lot of fun
until we weren't until we weren't
oh my god our lifestyle was out of
control and you know like you said 80 of
you know building wealth is behavior and
our behaviors were out of whack with our
income our income yeah
oh
my goodness wow
okay so um how long have you all been
married
um this will be seven years in june yeah
so you did dismiss before marriage
really yes we had two messes and then we
made one big mess when we got married
it was really nice that's so beautiful
so sweet
it's so romantic
very special
i mean you guys get married and it's
like you must have been thinking
everything's great and then all of a
sudden you're like one year in and
you're like holy crap well so
when when did when did you read the
house i don't want i don't want to put i
don't want to put words in your mouth
tell us what happened that's pretty much
what happened so we got married in june
of 2015.
um you know then we like continued our
frivolous lifestyle for about six months
and going on vacations and just like
kind of doing whatever we wanted having
fun being the like
the goal
um which we did but then we started to
merge our finances six months later and
gary actually you know came to me and
was like this is really a problem we
have way too much debt and i
was not
agreeing with him i was like this is
normal everyone has student loans
everyone has cars everyone has
that was like
that was bad but
um all right gary i'll give you 200 000
credit card but listen listen right i'll
give him that yeah i was like that good
that is bad um but i was like a big mile
person so i'm like well think of how
many miles working
i was bad so like he'll give us our own
airplanes yeah exactly
so
wow so gary um brought financial peace
to me i it took me a little while to get
on board but when he you know um
he was really the leader of merging our
finances because i'm like i don't want
to talk about money i don't want to do
it you're the accountant you're the cpa
make this go away gary yeah just like
fix it
you have the degree fixing hey i don't
know i don't i teach first grade i love
you you're amazing
you teach first grade so awesome right
you're a cpa right yeah and you had
six hundred thousand dollars in just
consumer debt exactly it's incredible so
i'm trying to help the little people now
i have a whole
lesson about it
but
but yeah so then he laid it all out for
me
so you went through financial peace at a
church together um so actually i read
the total money makeover book first and
that really just like blew my mind and
then i was hooked on everything right
from there and then
i found the at-home financial piece oh
okay it was actually like dvds yeah and
back in the day yeah yeah convinced her
too 2015 when people had dvd players
yeah
kind of convinced her to um
you know go through the program with me
and we kind of eased into it it was not
a you know
i wish it was like you know right away
but it took us probably the first
you know 12 to 18 months of the six year
journey to really clinch and get on the
same page and what was your best fight
oh probably the cutting the credit card
i feel like i really couldn't deal with
that
yeah that was
i mean we had 28 credit cards
28 yeah and it was bad yeah you know
when we started doing the debt snowball
you are giving america hope
yes we're here we just want to give
everybody we started
if you guys can do this by god anybody
can do it that's amazing i love you the
psychology behind the last one getting
hurt agreed to cut up that
i've
last
one
i used to cut them up at this on the
stage after an event and sign books for
hours and i've had people cry
they would just weep when we would cut
up their
probably cry when they cut up their
credit card it's
about this card since i was in college
like it's an old girlfriend yeah oh my
god
yeah it's hilarious oh man you guys are
fun i'm so proud of you because what
you've done is so
big it's so herculean
and so there had to be a moment in time
so you said it took about a year 18
months to get real serious and get it
dialed in and then we're like cut that
last card now we're game on and then
there had to be another moment where
the uh momentum shifted and you went
like hey we're going to win this
where was that
i mean we so our dead snowball had like
54 items on it yeah um because there's a
lot of yeah
um
28 credit cards yeah i think once like
after the first two years and we and we
got like a third of the way through the
list
momentum started picking up and we
started doing stuff that
you know like working side jobs and
selling stuff ahead of the house and
about that time i got my cpa license so
i started doing you know tax returns and
and i joined um
ramsey preferred coaching and uh started
coaching other people how to win with
money and um
it was really cool to you know do
something i was passionate about but use
that side income to speed up our
progress that's cool well and you got a
story
i mean you can tell people that stories
like me telling the story going broke
you know i mean it's like you know hey i
know you think i know you think your 26
thousand dollars in credit card debt is
bad but let me just tell you let me just
say
i couldn't tell you about that
so have you had the moment where your
your teacher check and your business
check is deposited and no payments you
have no payments
yeah we have yeah we have no we have a
mortgage but we don't have any consumer
debt payments that's why
it looks great you guys are amazing
you're so such a powerful thing you've
done
i mean i mean it's such an extreme
transformation
yeah when we first got married and you
know she just threw the the finances at
me and was like here you go and i had a
lot of stress and anxiety because i was
do i was living and breathing every day
and um you know put a lot of weight on
me and just to have her agree to come in
with me and work together and and share
the burden with me the last six years uh
it really like helped our marriage and
made us closer yeah so powerful
congratulations y'all too very very
powerful well we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you you're going
to be there before you know it you can
do this you can do anything man this is
so amazing so amazing and you're a neat
couple and thanks for letting us cry
with you there for a moment because it
just takes your breath away but you what
you've done is amazing that's that's the
story is the size of the mountain you
climbed all right to
000 paid off in six years of that over
200 000 credit card debt making 142 to
272. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
wow
you are
free
i love it no more excuses america they
just took them away from you ding ding
you thought you couldn't do it they did
it there it is
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day james 14 4 you
do not even know what will happen
tomorrow
what is your life you are a mist that
appears for a little while and then
vanishes
lillian dixon said life is like a coin
you can spend it any way you wish
but you can only spend it once
how you gonna do it what are you gonna
do
this is the ramsay show dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money leanne is in canada hi leanne
how are you
hi i'm doing well how are you guys great
how can we help
um well thank you first of all for
taking my call sure my husband's
actually an avid daily listener and
follower of your plan and he got me
hooked on it by playing the podcast on
our honeymoon last year and then gave me
the total money makeover as a like a
light beach read he's like a real
romantic
honeymoon i've ever heard of that's
awful
it actually was
it was a great way to start our marriage
so it worked out nice
very good
it must have been episodes that me and
george were on go ahead
oh there you go
um so we have no debt besides our house
which we owe about 330 000 on
um we made it our personal goal to try
to get off within five years as possible
and then we bought it in 2019 so we have
about three years left if we start to
fulfill our goal
we have a fully funded emergency fund
right now but my question is about a
decision that i have to make primarily
by
the 10th of march
right now i'm a 23 year old licensed
practical nurse who
um like i signed up for school online to
get my registered nurse through a
university in alberta
i'm finishing
three courses by the end of march and
needs to sign up for the new courses by
the tenth
i have about two years of full-time
school left if i'm to continue
um
the issue is that i unfortunately got
fired due to the mandates up here in
canada and could potentially lose my
nursing license
um and i'm not really sure what the
future of nursing is going to hold in
the next few years so to speak
um so i don't know
if it's going to be worth it for me to
keep taking the courses if i should work
harder than now
or casually or even if i should be
taking them at all because we're able to
cash full of my courses with my
husband's income and then a little bit
of my own but i'm not totally sure if
we'll be able to reach our goals paying
off the house that soon if i do school
on top of it
so
i'm not familiar with um
the overarching issues in uh
are the are the details i should say of
uh
why you were fired but i'm guessing that
you uh chose medical freedom you wanted
to decide what happens with you and and
they said you have to do something
regarding covey that you didn't want to
do
that's correct yeah okay and is that an
industry-wide thing i mean
she you said take your nursing license
because you choose not to be vaccinated
is that what you're saying
so that's a potential that they've sort
of been rumoring around
and i won't know that until probably
like the 24th of march
is when they're expecting to rule out
that mandated government
yeah i can't imagine
that they would lose the force they
would i mean i've been surprised before
so well they've they've lost their
entire trucking industry yeah on the
same exact issue yeah they shut the
trucking industry down
because truckers aren't they're not
working in canada because of this same
exact same thing and if all the nurses
or a portion of the nurses don't work
now
um and they're willing to do that on on
the issue of a vaccine or on the issue
of the power is really what it is but oh
my gosh wow well medical freedom
is a big deal uh being able to make your
own choices is a big deal so
you're i think i'm hearing
woven into this narrative that you're
saying
uh if that's how it's going to be i'm
not in nursing
kind of yeah that's kind of my
overarching yeah they're not they're not
going you're not going to acquiesce is
what you're saying
yes okay then you've got to choose a
different career and until you know that
i wouldn't spend a bunch of money on
further classes
i'd complete the ones you're in and
you can restart the classes next
semester can't you if this blows over
yes yeah i could technically and it does
work with the online system that i could
start them
sort of
any time but the one issue is because
i'm signed up in the courses already
it's a program
that times out
in i think it's seven years okay and
let me ask you this because i i don't
know how this works in your particular
situation but most colleges most
universities have a drop ad system that
there's so many days into the course you
can drop it and get a full refund right
could you sign up for it and how many
days down into march
or into april can you still drop
that course and get your money back yeah
jack could check with your advisor on
that
and you i mean this what's what's the
term here i don't know what this is in
canada is it three years for the for the
program you have two years left i'm
sorry you have two years left
yeah okay
and you've got a seven year clock you're
not going to hit that clock you're gonna
be fine
i think you're fine there um
i i heard another issue which is this
you and your husband have been gung-ho
gazelle intense and you created this
plan this idea that we're gonna have
this thing paid off in day x
and that is let's let's take the the
mandates off the table for a second and
you want to get get it paid off here
and
you want to complete your nursing degree
well it is actually going to cause them
to be able to pay it off because when
she completes that or pay will go up
it'll go up that's right so it's it's
six and a half dozen another i think you
have a long-term place so take the
mandates out if it's just staying in
school i'd rather see you go to school
and finish this program your pay will go
way up over especially over the long
term if you stay in nursing it will
that's right that's right you don't lose
your license and i'd rather you pay your
house off maybe a year later than your
plan that you all made up over dinner
one night then to yeah then to pause and
put yourself three or four years behind
making some major bank if you stay in
nursing of course yeah so yeah what i
would do is see if your drop ad date
that's what i call it from the old
school your ability to drop the class
and get a full refund on this next
semester
if it is far enough out that you will
have news about your license
before then
um
i think you know that you're in an
unfriendly environment
for
the near term even if they don't take
your license
agreed yeah
agreed and so you may make a decision on
nursing in general based on that too and
i'm not telling you to do that i'm just
saying that you know you've got the long
term okay i'm out of the business
because they're going to take my license
or they're going to mandate this from
now on and i'm not willing to do it so i
just i got to have another career boom
i'm out
peace out i'm not doing this right i'm
you're not going to violate my medical
freedom with totalitarianism i'm going
to vote with my feet i'm out peace out
um if that's the case you're already out
right yeah um
if uh
if you think that that this
will subside this this political
pressure
will subside and you can get back to
being a nurse without being vaccinated
and protect your medical freedoms
um sometime in the future
then you would stay on this track and
that's that's the judgment i can't make
because i don't know what the flip is
going on anywhere much less in canada
right so let me let me point this out
dave and i've had this call on my show
several times
once you decide i'm out
i will not let somebody tell me what to
do with my body i'm out
let that be the day you stop stewing
about it and be use that energy to go do
something else yeah right you've made
your call you've made your decision then
talking about it every day being angry
about it for the next six months it's
just choosing to live shorter it's like
true that's true if you quit any job
that's exactly right anything any
marriage
i don't like what's going on in this
company
i quit and as soon as you walk out the
door then keep going dust your sandals
off
going just keep going just keep going
you don't get any more space it doesn't
do any good for you
to constantly be looking in your vehicle
back because i got fired when i was 23
and i don't know why i got fired
i probably deserved it but the guy just
said pack your effing stuff in this fn
box and get the f out of my office now
and i went yes sir you should have
showered dude you know yeah that was it
and you know i have no idea what i did
but i probably deserved it i mean i was
a 23 little fart you know i'm still
being mad about it now
i
dust my sandals off next thing that's
right you know i'm not
apparently he had a problem you know
it's like goodness gracious right you
should you got to bathe dave you gotta
bathe gotta bathe i gotta shower gotta
brush those teeth gotta brush that tooth
brush the teeth brush that two that
tooth
[Music]
what's this hour of the ramsay show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you